So to wrap things up from
the perspective of coco values,
we learned a couple things.
We learned that they're efficiently
computable because we can do it
with a simple maximization and
a linear program added together.
What we end up getting is a behavior
that's utility maximizing for
the two players and
then they just split it up afterwards.
You can think of it as actually
decomposing a game into a sum of
two games,
one of which is purely cooperative and
one is just purely competitive.
We're just kind of shifting
around the utilities.
But we do it in a way that leaves us
with two really nice games to work with.
The result of that is unique.
There is a unique coco value for
each of the players.
Unlike a Nash where there can be
multiple different possible values
depending on which Nash you pick,
there's just the one coco value.
It's very convenient.
>> That is convenient,
because that means there's an answer.
>> There is an answer, yeah.
We've discovered that, in fact, you can
generalize this notion, not just to
matrix games like we talked about, but
actually to stochastic games in general.
And we get an algorithm
that we called coco-Q.
Coco-Q is a Q learning like
algorithm that uses coco values
to learn a strategy in
a stochastic game where
they actually can make little
side payments after each move.
So the two players move, and
then they divvy some stuff up.
And then they move again, and
they divvy some stuff up.
And those side payments actually end
up being sensitive to issues like,
we just got really unlucky.
Or I'm about to take an action
which is very risky.
And so, you're going to have to
pay me to take that action and
the payments have this nice
interpretations in terms of kind of
paying people for taking risky actions
and giving them the benefits of things.
It's neat because this actually
converges, this Q learning algorithm
converges inspite of the fact that the
coco operator is not a non expansion.
We've talked about non expansions in
the context of generalized Q learning.
This is a case where that
analysis actually fails.
But there's a different analysis that
you can use to show that the algorithm
actually converges so
that was surprising to me anyway.
I spent a lot of time worrying about
non expansions thinking that they were
the answer to everything and
they're going to do everything.
>> They are the answers to
everything except things that are-
>> Just not this thing.
>> Cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs.
>> [LAUGH] One thing that's worth
pointing out is that what you get at
the end of this is not necessarily in
equilibrium, which is to say once we've
computed what the cocoa values,
are I might not want to play that game.
I might not want to do the side payment.
I would rather get my value in a
national liberal or something like that.
And so that means that to
really make this work,
this side payment mechanism
has to be binding.
They have to agree in advance that,
whatever happens,
we're going to do what the coco
value says we should do.
And it's somewhat beneficial,
but making this binding agreement
in general is not beneficial.
It could be for some players,
they'd rather just not do it, so
it's not equilibrium in the same
sense as like Nash and correlated.
>> So we're going to have
to hire police officers?
>> We're going to have to hire police
officers to divvy up our bananas.
>> Okay, so just like the real life.
>> So thank you for
letting me have a chance to come in and
discuss cocoa values which otherwise,
we would not and got into.
>> Well, I guess also should I learn
from this the basically we should always
be doing cocoa or cocoa?
Yeah, we should always be doing cocoa
and hiring police officers things,
make things binding.
>> Well, I don't know.
I mean in general, you tend to
get a higher sum of values from
the coco value so paying the police
officers probably makes sense.
So it might be worth hiring them.
For specific games,
it's not necessarily true and
it doesn't necessarily kind of fit.
Another problem with the notion
of coco values is that
it doesn't really generalize if
you've got more than two players.
So this is specific to
the two player setting.
If you have three players, you can't
split it into, I don't know, three
matrices one of which is cooperative,
another which is competitive,
and the other which is I don't know,
combustible.
>> [LAUGH] Well,
what if you did all pair-wise games?
You'd have to get extremely lucky.
>> It doesn't seem like there's a
natural extension of this that works for
more than two players.
I mean it's an open problem and so
no one's shown that you can't do it.
So that could be a homework problem.
>> Yeah, that's cool and
then anyone who get, PhDs for everyone.
>> [LAUGH] PhDs for everyone.
Wouldn't that be nice?
>> That would be nice.
Okay so
we've gotten through coco values.
It's good, so we work together and
now we've done two solution
concepts in some detail.
>> Yeah.
>> Everybody wins.
>> That's the thing and
now we can actually do side payments
to kind of deviate afterwords.
>> So what are you going to give me?
>> I'm going to give you
back the pen [SOUND] so
that you can wrap up the section
three one [LAUGH] of game theory.
>> Sounds good.